[Applause]
[Music]
for some time I was like I live in LA
there's so many fake people
my friends moved up here and I always
visit and then I would drive through the
Hollywood Hills and see these homes and
I was thinking I need to do this you
know I need to be here for some people
they prefer to sit behind the desks from
8:00 to 5:00 I'll fall asleep it's all
about energy they drive a lot man you
guys sent from like Pasadena all the way
to Thousand Oaks to Hollywood to Beverly
Hills you get good music good fools but
you see why they pay the price from the
island of Guam it's a smile in 26 miles
long all my siblings are back home just
me out here I tell my clients that I'm
25 but I am you know early 20s the good
thing is is the clients that I work with
are all very young people like they're
all kind of doing the same thing as me
because I utilize social media the
people that I connect with on there are
younger people who are you know
youtubers or music artists or music
producers every client you know they
want a house in a different area so I'm
all over the place you know I'm running
from Venice Santa Monica all the way you
know Steve in Silver Lake
you get 12 pools a day if it takes you
half of an hour to clean a pool
it's definitely 20 bucks you can say
it's about managing time because if you
stay out your morning for 12 hours a day
you're pretty much making less than
minimum wage
I think the hours that I put in for both
jobs the most 16 the minimum 12 hours I
say yeah and that's just to check to
survive in California yeah
most the deals I do are like 5 million
and under mostly because a lot of my
clients are younger do you see the big
purchases that are like 20 million plus
those ones are usually older people yeah
it just makes sense you've been on the
planet longer you made more money you
can afford it I mean my office we have a
188 million dollar listing up in Bel Air
they were really trying to get jay-z and
beyonce to buy the home they thought it
was perfect for them
they'd have been trying to connect with
every single billionaire in the world
that's quite a risk you're taking me
pets because as the day goes by you keep
kneeling down on your knees about
padding tends to hurt hey how's it going
[Music]
so this is a a satang this is a chlorine
tank you mix chlorine and acid together
you can chemically make a mustard gas
that once makes chlorine and acid in the
wrong tank on accident and you can
endure like burn marks but inside your
system from the smoke itself you learn
your lessons after each things happen
properties when they're for sale you get
commission and it's if you're
representing the buyer the standard is
typically 2.5 percent of the purchase
price I wanna say how much you think
this house is like a townhouse Venice
three-point-three my wife provides it
for me she gives me everything that I
need to try to keep me safe out here
her name's April I worked at the UFC gym
in 2015 for her the gym was like a
getaway for her to go relax a lot of
people do that you know and I if I
didn't meet her I'll probably I used to
sleep in the back of the gym the UFC gym
life and you know I wake up trained
trained people from teaching class and
that's it you know that's like a
bachelor's lifestyle like now as I try
to help her you know pursue her career
first and also like try to secure
financial for her and my my to catch you
know like it makes me happy that's the
goal you know you don't even have to
live in it and you can make money from
it I had a client who I I showed him a a
house in Studio City for the LA Galaxy
soccer team did a photo shoot at the
house for one day and they paid him
$30,000 it's right now we're going to
see Catherine and she's leasing this
home for about fourteen thousand dollars
a month I commissioned somewhere around
7,000 you know Ali still you make a
whole lot less than that sale right
exactly and then and then in this case
scenario you know I found her this lease
and now this lease is turn has turned
into a sale you know cuz I'm gonna be
finding her property to buy now hey you
know I mean I was thinking like oh so
you're on the back side of the hill
that's fine it's way cheaper that's fine
you can drive down to Ventura or you can
drive Laurel Canyon it's la I have to
drive through this all the time yeah we
all just so used to it by now and gonna
make sure you have a place for all those
cars yeah I want to be able to at least
Park two to three cars in a garage and
at least to be able to put maybe like
four cars outside which is when gates
important to like this one right here so
yeah
several pool it does I'm picky but I'm
not I know what I like you know you're
like the dream client well it's good I'm
glad I thank you
a lot of people tend to complain they'll
watch you they look out the window and
had a lady she pretty much like a cheer
to make sure she does you do everything
that's on that checklist it went great
it makes my job so much easier when my
clients are actually my friends and she
said you know she'll spend up to 4
million
what is 2.5 percent of 4 million I love
to enter grades it's so good and it's
like not even expensive
I don't watch very many youtubers but I
definitely I've always watched Annie's
videos we're gonna go meet up with him
and this house has a nightclub in it so
it could be interesting life is
different now like you go to island slow
everyone's chilling here everyone's
moving my salary back there was like
what 15 thousand a year not a bad email
one of my deals just closed so let's go
get some coffee so this was actually
like small you know 2.5 percent of its
like roughly around $10,000 it's
definitely not bad for not even stepping
foot on this property oh you didn't yeah
one more on one more foot but wait
coworker she's checking you know like
usually a be late how many more pose you
got man this conversation you know it's
like it's not a lonely job but it's just
like you know you either you listen to
music or you talk to your other
co-workers you know it's just a dream
job but I like to work in animation but
I don't know how to draw so I'm not
really gonna try to pursue that you know
and you're like in your mind you can
configure it down to the very last screw
or very last sketch when when you
actually take paper to pencil doesn't
come out man I know you guys are excited
the good thing is it's only $23 but I
don't know how I got I got a parking
ticket dude literally look at the sign
and it says turn wheels to curb I did
not know that was even a thing dude
in my hometown Temecula my dad sells
yachts and he's built and designed boats
his whole life which is how I kind of
first got into that and then I was like
man this is pretty boring yeah I started
I started working under him like falling
him around and learning you know I just
didn't feel right you know my family
back home you know they're simple people
I have two sisters and one brother the
two oldest they're not as Bish's as the
two youngest we all have our reasons
what we do and why we do and one of the
reason why I moved out here is because I
wanted a better life yeah I'm just
looking at this house right now
three million
I want a little flavor you notice I just
plain water so this is the day you're
looking how to pump weeks throw rotate
your shoulder boom boom oh yeah you got
the movie theater in here it's here here
you got the full-on bar I don't even
drink one pump a but move in move
out - jab cross move in move out you
want to go home and get it like a foot
massage man after a day like this
tomorrow be even more busy it's all
about energy man like having good energy
in the class pushing people keep them
going and it's fun it's crazy to think
where am I gonna be in 5-10 years it's
just the most wild thought to me because
I don't know it no one yet from Guam has
never fought even for a bell my goal is
to just make it on to one of the
fighting organization giving glory man I
love to stand and bang all around it was
just a great day just granting away
15-hour shift today you know but it was
all good
[Music]
any job is great but like are you gonna
wake up someone next get up who loves
you from Steve are it's all about being
happy in the end man where's hey where's
the remote Julie